Hi. In a speaking exam, you may be asked to
share an opinion or have a discussion with
a partner about a topic. In this video, we’ll
have a look at how to express your opinions
and how you can agree or disagree with someone
else’s point of view.
Let’s have a look
at some phrases you can use to express your
opinions.
Some good phrases to use for expressing your
opinion are ‘I think’, ‘I believe’,
‘I like’, and ‘in my opinion’. For
example, if you were talking to your friend
about movies, you might say ‘I think that
action movies are the best’. You can also
express yourself with the negative forms of
these phrases. ‘I don’t like horror movies’,
or ‘I don’t believe the world needs any
more Transformers films’ are good examples
of sentences to express opinion.
Do you want to make your statements stronger?
You can use adverbs and adjectives to do this.
Instead of ‘I believe’ or ‘in my opinion’
you can use ‘I strongly believe’ ’ or
‘in my honest opinion’. Adverbs and adjectives
are useful for showing you’re serious about
a topic.
As well as expressing your opinion, it is
a good conversation skill to ask about other
people’s opinions. Phrases like ‘What
do you think about…’ and ‘How do you
feel about’ are good questions to keep a
conversation going. You might ask someone
‘what’s your opinion on climate change?’,
or use a question after you make a statement
- ‘I think the blue jacket is the nicest.
What do you think?’
Knowing how to agree and disagree with someone
else’s opinion is just as valuable as being
able to express your own opinion. You can
use short statements to show you feel the
same as the speaker. For example, if a friend
says ‘I think football is more fun than
tennis’, you could respond with ‘I agree!’
or ‘that’s right!’, or ‘me too’.
You can disagree with a statement in a similar
way. You could say ‘That’s not right’,
‘I don’t think that’s very good’,
or simply ‘I disagree’. If you have mixed
feelings on an issue you can use a more neutral
phrase. For example, ‘I’m not sure about
that’, or ‘I partly agree with you’.
It’s normal to explain your opinions as
part of a discussion. If your friend says
‘I think the LearnEnglish Teens channel
is great’, don’t just respond with your
opinion alone - use a statement to justify
it. You could say ‘me too; they have amazing
presenters!’, or ‘I agree. It’s way
more interesting than reading textbooks!’
For more tips on learning English and preparing
for your exam, subscribe to our channel and
visit the LearnEnglish Teens website where
you’ll find loads more learning material
to help you improve your English!